victimized mindset right now in order to
give you a way to navigate the world
that justifies a lot of your thoughts
and beliefs we're talking about race and
you're like it's giving misogyny it is
no you you what is calling out the
victimization of the race vibration you
feel the vibrations of misogyny give
misogynist why what did we say you I'm
not being funny if what what value do
you see and what what how do you value
women do you see the value of women like
are you Forin minutes ago I said that
I'm against feminis and I said yeah but
if you're going to call him a misogynist
she asked me a question I'm I said the
value of a woman motherhood is in
raising children I I said that we
respect mothers I opened the show by
saying that so what did I say that makes
you think that I'm a Mis that's a
serious allegation